je vais enfin félicité françois fillon
et alain juppé qui sont qualifiés pour
le second tour
ce sont deux personnalités de grande
qualité qui font honneur à la droite
française j'ai travaillé en confiance
avec chacun d'eux j'ai beaucoup d'estimé
pour alain juppé mais les choix
politiques de françois fillon me sont
plus proches
les électeurs qui m'ont fait confiance
sont actuellement libres de leurs
décisions
je leur demanderai cependant de ne
jamais emprunté la voie des extrêmes
la france mérite tellement mieux que le
choix du pire l'idée que je me fais de
mon devoir est de dire avec franchise
avec clarté avec loyauté que quelles que
soient mes désaccords passés avec lui
françois fillon me paraît avoir le mieux
compris les défis qui se présentent à la
france je voterai donc pour lui au
second tour de la primaire